I can't get enough of this one CNN
anchor Victor Blackwell struggled to
keep it together this is funny on
Wednesday after watching a viral clip of
two sea lions chasing people on the
beach yeah Marie we can relate sometimes
to be honest when we're on YouTube
Canada live you start laughing I just
can't stop and that's that is so me so I
totally get it but yes uh he lost it
watching the adorable sea lies charged
the crowd this was so funny I know in
California uh take a look and we'll see
you next time bye-bye everyone bye
and maybe that's what set off these two
sea lions on a beach near San Diego
so the are chasing the beachgoers as I
see and the Beach Boys are scrambling
look at how fast these sea lions move I
didn't think that they could waddle
quite that fast but they are chasing all
the beach goers away these are sea lions
they're charging basically the woman who
took the video says someone was trying
to take a photo of them when they
suddenly woke up are you enjoying this
is the Middle Sea Lion voices cursing
these people out into chasing them
you'd think the ocean would be big
enough for all of us but no oh man
that's what I needed oh the lead with
Jake Tapper starts right now